2 3 et ses parties
malgré la pandémie vincent guzzo
inaugure à saint jean sur richelieu un
tout nouveau cinéma et avec son visage
au plancher il compte bien brasser de
bonnes affaires et encore je pense de
l'argent faire c'est sûr qu'ils nomment
moins
qu'avant parce que les studios
américains oea en prennent de plus en
plus mais disons que c'est à nous
d'innover
innover la chaîne guzzo mise beaucoup
plus que sur son maïs soufflé il y à ici
d'un nouveau projecteur au laser et une
offre bonifiée de jeu pour faire
concurrence au visionnement en ligne
pour offrir d'autres choses que juste du
cinéma pour que l'expérience soit plus
complet pour que quelques uns
choisissent de venir chez nous au lieu
de rester chez eux pour attirer les
cinéphiles en salle et les éloigner de
leur écran de télévision il n'y a pas
que les cinémas guzzo qui innovent ici
au cinéplex à brossard on mise sur les
salles vip mais aussi depuis cette
semaine sur une toute nouvelle salle
immersive baptisé screen x il s'agit
d'un écran de 270 degrés
non parce qu'avec l'esprit nex voir mais
une autre façon pour aller voir un film
sur grand écran c'est qu'elle est venue
le nombre de films qui disponibles
instruit nex va être quand même plus
important de partout au canada les
cinémas bonifier leur offre
l'association des propriétaires de
cinémas du québec salue cette tendance
pillon à certains égards de certains
votes retard à rattraper déjà on a vu à
lachenaie
a été construite et une toute nouvelle
salle ultramoderne vous avez un exemple
à alma au secteur
j'ai rencontré votre nouvelle double
zéro avec le retour des films à grand
déploiement les cinéphiles retourne
nombreux au cinéma mais il ya une pente
à remonter vincent guzzo est confiant
que les cinémas sont là pour rester je
pensais que j'avais tout vu
aller au cinéma voir redevenir la sortie
d' ado par excellence même si j'ai
toujours dit je suis vraiment envie
d'avoir ton premier est ton premier jet
avec la première blonde dans le sous sol
chez ton père bon si les choses semblent
reprendre leur cours normal dans les
cinémas avec le variant au micro les
propriétaires de salles espère qu'en
2022 il ne rejoueront pas dans le même
film ici oui chez dupuis mais
radio-canada saint jean sur richelieu